thank you
[Music]
do you guys know the fresh and fit guys
we're massive fans
bro we based all our lifestyles on these
guys yep we're kind of red pill boys
dude you don't know who they are I
completely agree with everything I
actually don't know who they are what do
they do okay so these Russian fit boys
are mainly known for helping dudes get
over chicks okay so that they know
because girls are trying to trick you
when they're trying to get you in a
relationship they're just trying to use
you for your money and stuff drain your
bank and so now you know that and now
it's time to do something about it from
that school of thought where like all
chicks are [__] they're all gold
diggers they're good for nothing and you
just got they're just there I like them
they're like they're basically like
modern feminism is [__] let me tell
you what it really is like and why guys
today have it so hard and then like um
they're in Miami so that to me that's
like a Miami club scene thing and it's
so they have all these Club girls there
that aren't that you know smart and then
they kind of I'm dunk on them all day
they're really me they're really they're
hell of me dude but it's at the same
time
the girls are kind of delusional too so
they're I'm just like but you're it just
seems like cycle bullying like girls on
the podcast a ton it's like two of those
guys in like 30 girls it's like if the
view kept having guests that were like
idiot good looking guys yeah and then
they bring a lot of like only fans
models and it also has very strong
opinions on stuff that they disagree
with right okay YouTube this is fair use
[__] you guys okay leave us alone
[__] you algorithm describe your dream
man go ahead context this is just a
slice for bar okay but dude this is like
Jerry's finger dummy it's so funny
[Music]
um generous all right how much do you
got to make a year for you annually we
are minimal at least six figures okay
hundred thousand per year fantastic did
you just get moded do you think you just
got modded yeah because she said what's
that question like is that the girl's
wall and she's like are these six
figures no because he always that's his
prompt every single one of these girls
it's like he baits these girls into
answering it in the way that he knows
that they're gonna answer him because
they select these girls personally for
their structure you don't sound like a
fan she says she's a fan yeah I thought
you watched a [__] show dude yeah
um let me go into fan mode we catching a
lie again you said you're on their
patreon yeah I'm a big fan
okay no worries uh what age uh yeah age
range I'm 21. the max I'll go above me
is 10 years Max all right so I want it's
pretty reasonable
so 31. you'll go
maybe like two years
all right so 23 to 31 should we get it
right yeah yeah yeah so basically it's
just gender opinions and stuff yeah and
then you know it's pretty interesting
because I think they really make a lot
of content for guys that are heartbroken
because whatever reason they're single
they never got a girlfriend or you know
they make a lot of generalization yeah
they make a lot of generalizations I
mean they do want to fight against
modern feminism but to me it's like this
different side of the same coin
extremism on the left and the right and
the to it's just too much identity
[__] you know yeah and there's what
there's like one guy there's two guys on
that one and then there's this whole
thing called like rep red pilling
repilling is like um you know Matrix
right you have the blue pill the red
pill you wake up and then they're
talking it's all the Andrew Tate and the
that kind of world where it's like Mandy
man and then don't don't deal with this
woke feminism [__] it and then like book
feminism hurt like Society values yeah
on the extremes oh things like small
things yeah and they turn them into
narratives about bigger things and now
it's being done to them so
um
these are pictures of Myron Gaines who
is one of the freshest fit guys and now
people are saying that this guy's gay
allegedly I don't think he's gay maybe
but he might be
so where the one on the right the black
dude yeah and then oh damn he's having a
threesome that's him in a hotel room
with the dude he looks very different
yeah no it looks it looks like him why
is it giving advice on chicks if he
likes dudes I don't know so this came
out everyone's like this guy's gay just
came out and now people are taking the
small information
it's kind of funny that's kind of serves
the right dude it serves it right
everybody gotta get dunked on a little
bit hey I feel like we all have photos
like that too take yourself too
seriously sometimes yeah then this would
insult you well I think most of us would
be like this is incredible yeah yeah I
feel like Bart has one with like Josh
lip to lip oh yeah I feel like Barton
has a [__] million of these pictures
this guy kiss me on the lips tons of
times Mario was just rolling around with
Nick like two hours ago that's Jiu Jitsu
that's not the same it looks like it
looks the same that's Brazilian culture
yeah yeah you wouldn't understand it
yeah I I like watching a lot of this
[__] though because it's it's like my
Jerry Springer yeah to see like the
funniest like thoughts you know it's
just hilarious to me so he's come out
and said those are taken out of context
which I don't think you should do yeah
you can't say that you should have been
like hell yeah
boys can't love boys dude
is funny yeah yeah yeah yeah that's how
you know you take yourself a little
thing yeah dude I'll hug Bart right now
with their shirts off right now dude no
I won't I won't do it I'm just kidding
I'm all insecure about it
but no they they say some things about
ladies and general words like
like they'll have thoughts about
relationships in marriage and these guys
don't even sound like they've been in a
long-term relationship no that's the
funny thing about that yeah a lot of
these guys in the space right that are
giving hella advice they're fighting for
Traditional Values none of them are
traditional none of them are married or
have girlfriends and even the girls in
the space they are actually the
feminists that they talk about like they
run companies they're single they don't
have a boyfriend
they're not submissive to men they're
like powerful women too so I'm like to
me that's kind of weird because you're
not practicing what you're preaching
so how can you be a leader in that space
if they were like about that life I
would be really like oh that's cool man
you it's like you believe what you're
preaching but you're pretty much a
hypocrite if you're not doing what you
know you you say like others should be
doing like if you really are about
Traditional Values if you really are
about the marriage
um marrying young and all this stuff
then I'd like to see them actually do
that what is Traditional Values anymore
so they talk about like Ben Shapiro
points
Spencer beer is like uh married I've
been married to one woman I'm I've never
been with anybody else I have a lot of
kids like this is completely different
[__] this [__] is more like gender and
dating and like it's like more gender
politics and like well when they talk
about marriage they're not talking about
like like it's it's in the positive for
men to be married
that's like that's their that's their
take like that's the red button knock
off you and yourself are beneficial for
women to get married than it is for the
man and that like a man to prove his
love to a woman is essentially getting
married to her because like he's
sacrificing a lot more than the woman is
just because of how you know she could
divorce him take half the money
um she has more leverage in that regard
like that's that's the argument on that
side as far as like the red pill and you
use the big examples like Basil's
getting cleaned out by his ex yeah
getting clean the [__] out I feel like
every episode they use the the the
famous quote of like it you want to be a
key that opens up all locks you want to
be that guy like that's a guy that's the
analogy of guide a lock that gets opened
up by a bunch of different Keys that's
not very good and that's what you ladies
are that's what he that's when he kind
of talks [__] to like all these girls
around and a lot of them are like uh
some of them are like only fans girls or
most of them are like most of them are
yeah that's the part that makes it hard
it's like he brings them on because they
like what clean it's an easy dunk yeah
they know that they're gonna say the
same talking points of like oh I want a
guy that has six figures and all this
[__] they want a guy that's really
wealthy yeah and so they could be like C
you're delusional yeah you think you can
get a guy like that and it's just like
what is this 31 of men like do you think
you're the point one percent of women
yeah that's always what do you want to
be a key for when you can be a locksmith
they do have good they do have good
stats like with like with that it is
true but it is to shut down a person
that doesn't have a thing to say back to
you but it's also interesting right
you're doing it to kids that's what it
sounds like it sounds like kids arguing
about dumb [__] they do have certain
guests very rarely like I think Abba was
on at one point or Destiny was on at one
point and like the way that they
approach them is completely different
than some of these women because they
can actually fire back with some some
questions or answers that actually put
them through the loop and they're like
oh [__] like my structure is getting
completely tipped off the rail so like
those are always really funny because
it's like they don't talk to these women
the same way that they talk to some of
these other guests that they have on and
they're primarily mostly men yeah
um it's just like it's an easy dunk it
goes entertaining but yeah it is bad if
you're taking that as like oh that's my
new Credo I'm gonna live like this they
have a big following it's the same thing
as like going into a university and slam
dunking on all these children
if you're a politician or you know when
they do those Crowder ones or yeah yeah
like and then like people want to ask
questions and they're like oh they got
[__] owned and wrecked and I'm like
of course they're like intellectually
yeah stunted kids still they're not
they're still learning the world they
don't know [__] so like for me like
everyone has their set of ideology
beliefs philosophy whatever and then
you're gonna Champion that thought cool
because that's what you believe in but
for me it's like practice what you
[__] preach if this is who you are
is your life this way this is like how I
feel about limousine liberals and like
fake ass conservative it's like do you
really like for me I'm like okay Ben
Shapiro you're hilarious because you
don't really I'm well yeah
he he has gay friends he'll never go to
their marriage to me that's just
autistic as [__] like you you're just
not socially smart but I I do the fact
that he thinks of being gay is just
about like like coming and coming
buckets it's so funny to me because that
just makes me think that like he's like
I know I would come it's like where my
G-spot is I know that yeah but
my point to that is at least he sticks
to his beliefs and his lifestyle matches
with what he's saying so then even
though I disagree I'm like this fool is
living and walking his system of belief
and your argument doesn't fully crumble
because you're being hypocrite exactly
but these guys will have like they'll
they'll have it only fans [__] come on
as a guest and then they just yell at
him the whole time yeah but then it's
like you you you're the kind of guy that
pays for only fan but then you're just
mad at that you're mad that it exists
yeah that you are falling for it and
also I don't I don't know any women that
actually look at them as like Rico Suave
is like I want to [__] them they are
like the alpha a Pity yeah
we know the Miami chicks exist right we
know yeah
but seeing maybe it is I think it's
catered to that that uh frame of thought
yeah it's like I get what like what a
Crowder does by going to colleges it's
like he's trying to find the common
sentiment and shut it down he's like oh
everyone who shares this now has a
rebuttal and has to do better next time
but then this is like if you're a good
guy you don't want a girl like that
anyway so why do you care what she
thinks yeah right those rules don't
apply if you're a good dude a good woman
doesn't even have that life they don't
start with stats and the guy that I like
yeah I get to know the guy first right
rather than just arbitrary and
everything else is a bonus yeah but they
do have so they do have some very harsh
good points so sometimes for sure yeah
but like broken clock is right towards
the day right yeah but then you don't
have to like like they'll tell a girl
like who she thinks like she wants this
in a guy but she has a kid already and
he's like you realize a guy
yeah on the flip side though it is kind
of funny when they break down a
delusional overly confident egotistical
human being that's a narcissist when you
can clearly tell she believes she
genuinely believes that like one day a
billionaire Prince Charming is gonna
and then I'm like but what are you doing
to actually align yourself to get that
yes and they're hella entitled and I'm
all like I can't believe these girls
exist present Samuels used to do the
same thing you would find all these
women that had that and he would do that
but then this is the part that's weird
is when did it become our job to have to
seek these women out and set them
straight it's not you pass them by and
then you find someone else that you like
it's not you don't stop and lecture them
like you go oh these are your thoughts
they don't match mine yeah well you know
what good luck yeah but we're not
supposed to sit them down and be like
you're not worth it you're not worth it
you're not worth it like and let's do
the show for three hours it's also
cathartic right so some people like say
you're a short guy and you watch these
guys clowning this chick because she
wants a six foot plus guy and you get to
sit there and watch this chick get like
look like an idiot but like it really is
just her preference yeah like she likes
that yeah
probably not yeah yeah you don't you
never know they grow on trees in my
house
I just don't like
kicking someone while they're down while
you masquerade as if it's helping them
by setting them straight all you're
doing is just talking [__] to someone
because it feels good to you yeah it's
like you get to shut down a girl who
would not pay attention to you otherwise
right but it's like who cares you don't
need to pay attention to them either
that's the thing and I'm I'm wondering
who the is it is the audience like
divorced men who are bitter
um because like a lot of single single
men single men I think there's a lot of
single men who our friendships
or angry guys who like maybe even turn
down maybe that I mean I think it's a
combination of like a bunch of people
like who's who's on next shark Joe yeah
yeah inspirational Asians
part is that the true answer really is
the most boring one it is like hey guess
what you don't even have to engage with
any anybody like you just have to find a
person that matches you and they might
be nice and if you're nice great job and
also they're talking about like like a
very minute major like up
people like it's so specific but they
talk in general the classification thank
you yeah that's what it is well it's a
lot of straw man if you watch that show
long enough you're gonna be like I hate
women too
foreign
[Music]